en este vídeo vamos a hacer algunos
ejemplos sobre rectas paralelas y
perpendiculares así que déjenme notarlo
tengo las rectas paralelas paralelas y
también voy a hablar de las rectas
perpendiculares
rectas perpendiculares y claro también
puedo tener rectas que no sean ni
paralelas y perpendiculares y bueno este
es un pequeño repaso por si no recuerdas
o si no has visto todo esto antes las
rectas paralelas nunca se intersectan
así que si por aquí tengo dos ejes
déjame dibujar por aquí un par de que es
este va a ser mi hijo james muy bien y
por aquí tengo mi eje x perfecto y voy a
poner que este es mi hija jane de lujo y
esto de aquí es mi eje x y supongamos
que me tomo no sé una recta está aquí va
a ser una recta que está en este plano
cartesiano y se va a ver más o menos así
entonces una recta paralela se va a ver
más o menos así se va a ver más o menos
así ojo no es que sean la misma recta o
que tengan la misma ecuación pero lo que
sí deben de tener es la misma pendiente
es decir si la primera cambia una cierta
cantidad si tenemos no sé que el cambio
en con respecto al cambio en x nos da
una cierta cantidad entonces esa misma
cantidad tiene que cambiar esta recta
ese mismo cambio y entre ese cambio en x
para que la recta sean paralelas y es
por esto que nunca se intersectan
entonces tienen la misma pendiente
déjame rotarlo tienen la misma pendiente
la misma pendiente por su parte las
rectas perpendiculares son en cierta
forma lo opuesto o bueno al menos
depende del punto de vista que lo veas
si decimos que esta es una de mis rectas
perpendiculares y tomo por acá a esta
recta de color anaranjado como la otra
recta
bueno pues las rectas perpendiculares no
solamente se intersectan sino que se
intersectan en un ángulo de 90 grados se
intersectan en un ángulo de 90 grados en
un ángulo recto y no voy a demostrarlo
aquí y de hecho esto lo pruebo en la
lista de álgebra lineal pero si decimos
que la recta de amarillo esta recta aquí
tiene una pendiente de m supongamos que
ésta de aquí tiene una pendiente de m
entonces la recta de color naranja esta
recta de aquí va a tener una pendiente
de menos 1 entre m
de menos 1 / m es decir sus pendientes
deben de ser la inversa negativa la una
de la otra ahora dada esta información
que te acabo de dar veamos un montón de
rectas y averigüemos si son paralelas o
si son perpendiculares o si no son ni
una ni otra y para hacer esto vamos a
fijarnos en las pendientes así que
veamos una recta pasa por los puntos 4
menos 3 y menos 80 la otra recta pasa
por los puntos menos uno coma -1 y -2 6
así que vamos a averiguar la pendiente
de cada una de estas rectas a la primera
recta le voy a poner a su pendiente el
nombre de m1 y lo voy a hacer con este
color vino la pendiente 1 y bueno para
obtenerla vamos a sacarla de la
definición de pendiente por dos puntos
así que la pendiente 1 va a ser igual
veamos va a ser el cambio en james es
decir menos 3
- 0 / el cambio en x entre el cambio en
x que es 4 - menos 84 - menos 8 menos 8
y esto cuánto va a ser bueno pues
observa que esto es lo mismo que menos
tres menos tres me queda en la parte de
arriba y en la parte de abajo tengo
cuatro menos -8 estos dos signos se
convierten en positivo y por lo tanto me
queda 4 más 8 lo cual es 12 menos 3
entre 12 y se va dividimos el numerador
y el denominador entre 3 me va a quedar
que esto es lo mismo que menos un cuarto
de lujo ya tengo la primera pendiente m
1 esto para la primera recta y si nos
fijamos ahora en la segunda recta qué va
a pasar con su pendiente bueno para la
pendiente de la segunda recta a la cual
le voy a poner el nombre de m2 nuestra
pendiente m2 quién va a ser y me va a
quedar bueno veamos menos uno menos seis
menos uno menos 6 recuerda el cambio en
james entre el cambio en x que es menos
1 - menos 2 - 1 - menos 2 muy bien y
cuanto va a ser esto bueno en la parte
de arriba tengo menos 7 menos 7 y en la
parte de abajo que tengo menos 1 - menos
dos bueno esto es exactamente lo mismo
que menos uno más dos y menos uno más
dos es uno por lo tanto la pendiente 2
va a ser menos 7 muy bien pero es
momento de que observes que sus
pendientes no son iguales por lo tanto
no son
paralelas y tampoco son inversas
negativas así que tampoco son
perpendiculares estamos en el caso en el
que es ninguna de las dos no son
paralelas y perpendiculares
ni perpendiculares es decir estas dos
rectas se intersectan pero no en un
ángulo de 90 grados no son paralelas ni
perpendiculares ninguna de las dos muy
bien hagamos un par de ejemplos más para
seguir con la misma idea
así que por aquí tengo el segundo de
ellos muy bien de nuevo tenemos una
recta que pasa por dos puntos y otra
recta que voy a poner con este color que
pasa por otros dos puntos así que veamos
sus pendientes y para eso vamos a hablar
de la primera recta y la pendiente m 1
muy bien cómo sacamos la pendiente m 1
bueno recuerda el cambio en y entre el
cambio en x me va a quedar 14 menos
menos 214 menos -2 esto dividido entre
menos tres menos uno
3 - 1
y cuántos esto bueno pues vamos a
hacerlo 14 + 2 recuerda que estos dos
signos se vuelven positivos eso me queda
16 y abajo tengo menos tres menos uno lo
cual es menos cuatro y bueno 16 entre
menos 4 es lo mismo que menos 4 estás de
acuerdo y cuál es la segunda pendiente
bueno pues vamos a obtener la m2 va a
ser igual y me voy a fijar primero en
este punto me va a quedar 5 - menos 3 ok
esto dividido entre menos 2 - 0 - 2 - 0
de nuevo aquí tengo un par de signos
negativos lo cual se convierte en
positivo y 53 es 8 y en la parte de
abajo me quedan simplemente menos 2 y
bueno entre menos 2 también es menos 4
así que estas dos rectas son paralelas
tienen la misma pendiente déjenme
escribirlo
paralelas y te encargo que encuentras
las ecuaciones de estas dos rectas y que
las gráficas por tu cuenta con esto vas
a verificar que en efecto son paralelas
así que vamos muy bien vamos a hacer un
último ejercicio uno más y va a ser este
que tengo acá de nuevo tenemos una recta
que pasa por estos dos puntos y es un
ejercicio donde necesitamos encontrar su
pendiente así que vamos a hacerlo la
pendiente 1 de la primera recta quién va
a ser bueno pues tiene estos dos puntos
así que vamos a sacar su pendiente si
empiezo ahora con este punto que me va a
quedar me queda menos 3 - 3 menos tres
entre y ahora como empecé con este punto
voy a empezar en la parte de abajo
también con este valor x menos seis
menos tres menos 6
- 3 - 3 y cuánto es esto
bueno pues veamos - 3 - 3 es menos 6 y
abajo me queda menos 6 3 lo cual es
menos 9 y bueno aquí los signos se
cancelan y si divido entre 3 el
numerador y el denominador me quedan dos
tercios dos tercios muy bien y cuál va a
ser la segunda pendiente
bueno pues leamos la otra recta pasa por
los puntos dos menos ocho y menos 64 así
que mi pendiente 2 va a ser igual y
bueno voy a empezar con este punto menos
8 - cuatro menos cuatro esto entre dos
menos menos 62 menos menos 6 y bueno acá
arriba me queda menos 12 y en la parte
de abajo estos dos se vuelven positivos
me queda 8
ok y si ahora divido todo tanto el
numerador y el denominador por 4 me va a
quedar menos 3 entre 2 observa que estas
dos pendientes son inversas negativas
una de la otra
si tomo menos 1 entre dos tercios entre
dos tercios esto es lo mismo que menos 1
que multiplica a tres medios y bueno
esto es lo mismo que menos tres medios
es decir estos dos valores son inversos
negativos uno del otro
recuerda volteas el numerador y el
denominador y le cambias el signo así
llegas a la otra pendiente así que estas
son rectas son perpendiculares son
y te encargo que encuentras las
correspondientes ecuaciones al menos ya
tienes las pendientes ya las encontré
por ti y después gráfica las para que
verifiques por tu cuenta que en efecto
son perpendiculares